lucas g alito this year four starts
era five and a half inflated by the last
start all in all he's been pretty good
seven walks 26 strikeouts and he will
use that straight change today
now the 2-1 to cabrera rifled
to deep left field that baby's gone
solo two out shot from miguel
cabrera the tigers have drawn first
blood in chicago
he got a fastball from geolito inner
half of the plate
and he didn't miss second home run of
the year and the tigers take a
one-nothing lead in the first
got those hands and we'll listen in
he knew it too man that's as good a
swing
as miguel cabrera has had all season
long
tigers have jose rorania on the mound 2
54 on the year for yolong to start the
home stand
arena will fire over to first and now
anderson
has to go back to the bag as scope
throws it away
it'll go down the left field line
anderson will score
eaton to second and it's tied at one boy
i gotta say
if tim anderson did that by design he's
brilliant
that pick-off he got himself a nice big
secondary lead
tim scores easily the sox have a run on
two hits and still nobody out
tied at one lucas giolito off his
self-proclaimed worst start of his
career
you look at his expected era right
around where he was
last year oh two struck him out
fastball after a couple change-ups and
good room goes down
for round number one that's a well
located high fastball you see where yas
wants it and literally
lucas fills up the glove two strikes to
count
change up for strike three third
strikeout for geo
grossman stranded three k's for gia lito
early we go to the bottom of the third
one down for mercedes two and one
mercedes left side nice pick by
candelario and he throws it away in
right field
start the carousel sox will get a run
eaton scores moncada to third on the
third
error by the tigers for not treating the
ball with a great deal of respect so far
tonight
candelario really had improved his
defense
but you'd never know it by what he's
doing tonight he couldn't get the handle
and by the time he did
he threw it away at second base this
part of it's good but he couldn't get
the ball
out and by the time he did he actually
threw it with his palm so that's two
errors already we're only in the third
and two errors on candelaria bottom of
the fourth
2-1 white sox 1-2 hit on the ground that
one eats up
scope off his glove lamb is safe at
first
might be their fourth error just got on
him and the tigers are going to have to
look for answers
fourth straight inning with an error his
scope is a second baseman
if he knows where castro is setting up
he just goes back to the bag because
castro's right in front of that easy
play for him
scope made it into a more difficult play
and if he backhands it it's still going
to be difficult
because urania has to get to the back
tim's like let's go he's rubbing his
hands together
let's see who's better
the second base that's off a castro
tim stops at second base the tigers
have an error and inning i was gonna i'm
just gonna tell you that they've been
wonderfully consistent each inning
they've committed one error
and that will be number five how about
irania like guys
i'm a ground ball pitcher your mean
mercedes leads off for the chicago white
sox bottom of the sixth inning
but first this off to ricochet and this
is
overthrown and the tigers have somehow
successfully wobbled again defensively
well i i think that's probably going to
be a base hit but if you've got
five and who's going to make an error
this inning you're hanging by a thread
right now
oh there's a base here it is a base hit
by the way if you're in a camera well
tonight
you probably just duck when the balls
hit on the ground because you never know
if it's coming your way
yes money grandal bounced into a double
play last time up grounded to second
his first trip to the play the strike
one
swinging the ground ball into the shift
backhand flip from castro to good room
over to first to get yasmani grandal
jose uranya does it again that did go
into the books as a hit but still
a play that we know candelario can make
and again he just
doesn't let it bother him he keeps
getting ground balls
to give his infielders the chance to
turn a double play
impressive it's really
[Music]
a incredible to short quickly the first
and the white sox are retired another
nice job
by jose arena in the sixth to keep it
2-1
wilson ramos now 33
on the ground as well line drive to the
gap in right center field and that's
going to get by garcia
he's going to try to cut it off it's on
the warning track and deep right center
rounding third heading home is willie
castro and he will make it without a
throw
there's the deep drive we were looking
for wilson ramos crushes one up the
right center field gap by leori garcia
the tigers have tied it to two in the
seventh wilson
ramos first rbi in almost two weeks
now nico goodrum who has a soft fly ball
to center
see if goodwin can bring it home turns
on one sends it to deep right field
that goes adam eaton still going back he
stumbles and it's over the wall
a two-run homer for nico goodrum
and the tigers have stunned lucas
giolito
and the white sox here in the seventh
and it's gone a home run
nico goodroom with a shot to right
towering fly ball the tigers have taken
a 4-2
lead here in the seventh inning wilson
ramos for the double
nico goodrum with number three four
two tigers what a game jose uranya
strong game lots of trouble in lots of
trouble
gets a couple strikeouts and
mega ground ball double plays four on
the evening
on five tiger airs but they hung in
there and the tigers
somehow find themselves with the lead as
they go to the top of the eight
strongly behind jose urania what a heck
of a job and kept his composure
jonathan really trying to looks like
he's really trying to hit the ball out
of place 1-2
pounded left center field
gone an insurance run here in the eighth
courtesy of jonathan scope's second
homer of the year
jonathan scope crushes one to left
center on a night when the swing was not
looking good to say the least two
strikeouts and a weak ground ball
that's what the tigers need from there
now most days
every day first baseman two hitters in
the middle of this order that the tigers
need to hit with some power
cabrera and scope both with home runs
tonight gregory soto working the ninth
here
two hits tonight for eaton on base three
times
2-1 grounded nice play at first base
and soto covers the bag to get the final
out
he retires chicago one two three in the
ninth
and detroit snaps the nine-game losing
streak to chicago